nos encontramos en la provincia de
saporilla a menos de 15 kilómetros de la
línea que divide a las tropas rusas y a
las tropas ucranianas Esta es una
provincia que tiene el 60% de su
territorio o un poco más en control de
las fuerzas de Moscú después de ese
avance que hicieron después de esa
invasión a gran escala del año pasado a
partir de entonces la línea de batalla
se quedó estática Y ambos ejércitos han
ido creando líneas de defensa
Especialmente los rusos que se dice han
creado tres fuertes líneas de defensa de
Cara a esta contraofensiva que estarían
planeando los ucranianos en los próximos
días y semanas aquí hablábamos hoy con
una unidad que opera drones y ellos
dicen que incluso los rusos se siguen
preparando al otro lado ven como crean
nuevas fortificaciones Pero también
dicen de del nerviosismo que podría
haber en sus tropas la levantan todos
los días a las cuatro de la madrugada
según ellos pueden darse cuenta en estos
videos y los ponen en sus posiciones
todo el día y así Día tras día a la
espera de que los ucranianos lancen esa
contraofensiva pero como están y como ya
ha sucedido en los últimos días están
jugando al factor sorpresa lo que sí nos
confirman es que hay mucho más
movimiento de tropas en esta zona Aunque
nadie quiere hablar realmente de la
contraofensiva Aunque ellos dicen que
están bastante motivados y que
eventualmente les darán la orden de
avanzar pero también lo que pasa aquí es
ataque es más frecuentes de la
artillería rusa hacia poblaciones
especialmente civiles Este era una
tienda donde la población venía a
comprar sus víveres fue atacada hace dos
semanas otras tres viviendas fueron
atacadas esta semana murieron tres
civiles y esto dice que se ha ido
incrementando Día tras día de Cara a
esta contraofensiva en la que hace que
la atención sea mucho